welcome back to new rock stars it's a
big question this is the show that gives
you too much information about all those
nerdy mysteries like the MC multiverse
and how thanks to one division now it
might not actually look like dr.
Strange's acid trips
yes that's exciting yeah we're moving
forward also welcome back to both of us
being in the same room good to you guys
this is pretty serious but we were
testing our monogamous relationship and
we said each of us gets a Hall Pass
get to pick one person we tried it out I
pick marina you pick Tommy yeah exactly
and while fun it made me more appreciate
what I was missing from my other tender
teddy tender teddy and you know it
that's what the hall passes are designed
for it's like the pina colada song it's
not what you're missing it's what you
already have why do people think we're
gay for each other well this week's
question quickly quickly okay so this
one I have assigned you this week is a
big question appropriately for this show
yeah we covered in rogue theory last
week what we thought the Wanda vision
impact might be on the MCU
but I actually want to know what
actually is the Marvel multiverse light
it's a very good question because
multiverse has come up a lot before and
people keep saying they they just say oh
multiverse is coming we got an MCU face
for a movie called multiverse of madness
but no one really quite knows exactly
what the multiverse will look like Wanda
visions given us some more information
so let's just explain everything we know
about the multiverse as has been
established in Canon comics and movies
so far so the first time we heard the
word multiverse in the movies as you
remember it wasn't dr. strange the first
dr. strange the ancient one says a vast
multiverse and then the context for that
was strangers just kind of floating
through different watercolor paintings
right and so it's just somebody versus
just a bunch of abstract collection of
paintings that we can fly through like
the quantum realm yes yes the Dark
Dimension in hands is the multiverse
just hands
well the thing is is the multiverse in
the comics when it was introduced it's
far more elaborate more complex more
intricate and also in a way more
grounded because it's an it's a spectrum
of infinite parallel realities with just
slight alterations different heroes just
different contexts different genres so
we saw this in the Sony spider-verse
into the spider breath where there was
like Miles Morales spider-man who came
from Earth 1610 Peter Parker the prime
earth-616 spider Gwen Stacy earth 65 but
where did they get these numbers right
there are these numbers I mean there's
like thousands and thousands of these
marble universes Peter porker is from
Earth 83 11 penny Parker's from Earth
one four five one two that doesn't mean
there are over 14,000 established
different universities canonically it
just means like there are infinite
numbers in a lot of those pages have not
been filled in yet and the day
specifically are only getting from the
first 15 thousand and not earth 1
trillion 6 on it you know whatever well
big numbers like that are actually
pretty interesting because the MCU the
cinematic universe has been established
as one of those universes it's numerical
designation is earth one nine nine nine
nine nine five minutes so like
potentially two hundred thousand
realities so if you think about it that
means the whole history of Robert Downey
jr. Tony Stark and Tom Holland Peter
Parker and dad's guardians and the
singularity that created the Infinity
stones that's all real it's all real
we're another one and it's all connected
to everything we've seen in the comics
it's all connected everything in into
the spider versus even because they
might have the same kind of numerical
designations getting back to how this is
gonna look in phase four with one
division and multiverse of madness
multiverse of madness being a Doctor
Strange sequel kind of seems like that's
the direction they're gonna go they're
gonna more abstract trippy surreal
dimensions did you just lose some booze
don't lose the booze you got to finish
that I'll absorb it through my skin
party foul
so we don't are we just looking at more
like dream dimension stuff more like dr.
strange hell well yeah but if Kevin
Feige wanted to be true to the
multiverse as we know it in the comics
and as it has
been established in minor clues
throughout the series so far the real
Marvel multiverse of a source should be
more grounded it should be like else
worlds where it's just like different
power dynamics different heroes
different villains so just to kind of
run down the the subtle subtle clues
we've gotten of the multiverse so far
ant-man the wasp of all films actually
gave us probably a pretty big hint of
the physical possibility of the
multiverse remember there was a lecture
by Bill Foster where he discussed
subatomic particles existing
simultaneously in multiple parallel
realities he used that phrase and there
was also indoor the dark world to that
moment where dr. Erik Selvig was ranting
to the other people in the retirement
home including Stan Lee and on the board
behind him was Schrodinger's cat and all
these other theoretical physics terms
about these this very idea of multiple
planes of existence real quick it's
obvious that you are the dr. Erik Selvig
of the rock star so good to have an
analogue it's definitely a little bit
grating my guy so if you remember
avengers endgame tried to apply some of
these concepts to how they did time
travel I would say it wasn't very clear
they just kind of threw out some
Planck's constant and whatnot but they
talked about how major alterations to
the past would create new parallel
timelines but and it would leave the
original timeline unaffected but we
never really saw what those hypothetical
timelines would look like we always
stayed in the perspective of our
original timeline I felt like when I was
watching endgame that there was this
other like kind of obvious setup because
of these time-travel elements I remember
reading the comic once that had mr.
fantastic saying that that there's no
such thing as time travel that's right
it's like you're just traveling to
another dimension and then you'd already
do anything and now you think you're
like I saved the world and it's like no
there's another dimension with the world
did not get saved now you thought you
traveled through time you're just
dimension-hopping yeah and so anytime
you ever seen time travel you actually
saw a multiverse but we know that Loki
when he escaped with the tesseract he
created a new branch line he's alive now
and the other mc2 universe he's dead so
we have two universes where
Loki for the cat is alive or dead
shorteners Loki but we also know that
old cap might have lived in a new branch
reow right as well well it has to be
different right just by taking up space
that wasn't too
you know right before right you know the
guys that Peggy Carter was you know
entertaining in the evenings was must
not have been cap
so we also know with Loki that it's
gonna bring in this agency called the
time variance Authority which they kind
of keep track of like people who disrupt
the timelines and they they're like the
policing agency for that so maybe with
this show they'll start giving us a very
clear layout of all the different
timelines in the multiverse like Rick
and Marty yes and then the showrunner of
Loki is Rick and Morty Rider so clearly
they're trying to bring in this idea of
a multiverse Oh also there was a real
subtle throwaway detail and Avengers
endgame that you only really noticed by
like listening to a very carefully Peggy
Carter mentions a guy named Braddock in
the 1970s
[Music]
the name Brian Braddock is Captain
Britain so captain britain was an
alternate UK version of Captain America
and later on the captain Britain would
actually oversee the Captain Britain
Corps which is kind of like a League of
alternate Avengers who are all from
different dimensions and they all kind
of work together to solve
multi-dimensional problems so already
we're starting to get a sense that there
might be a captain ridden core that is
overseeing this multiverse second
currently already exists and that was
setting up this idea of a multiverse so
1 division 1 division is taking what
seems to be the biggest step forward in
its display of the multiverse as its
going to be an MC you like the brief
trailer for this shows want a Maximoff
you know jumping in and out of these
different sitcom realities but vision is
still alive we don't know what is
causing this
maybe she's trapped in like a spell or
she's being cursed or maybe she's like
transported her mind inside visions mind
and that's what we're getting there but
like clearly this idea of vision being
alive again like that is Marvel saying
this is the idea the multiverse
characters who have died mm-hmm they can
come they can be alive again in
different else world stories and in
different forms RDJ said hey it's
theoretical I could show up like once or
twice exactly in along with Loki as well
and the reason why I want to say this
could be alternate realities is because
obviously the reference point for the
one division series is going to be House
of M in some form and in house of M
Scarlet Witch is going through this kind
of a psionic break where she's
chaotically resetting realities one
reality where mutants are in charge
they're like the dominance group in
society reality where she has two mutant
kids and then at the end of it a reality
where mutants are mostly wiped out so
that seems to me what they're kind of
doing with Wanda vision so this idea of
reality flipping in reality resetting
the MCU is saying expect to see
different genres different kinds of pop
culture things where characters don't
realize they're in different realities
but they've just always lived in this
history where the rules have always
worked this way a reality where things
are horror ear yes Horrors did all this
profession and I think the big thing
with one division it's establishing
Wanda Maximoff as the conduit for this
multiverse switching like the idea of
one division it's on a TV set like it's
her vision she can kind of change the
channel on the multiverse so however
exactly the multiverse plays out she's
gonna be the key to it
characters are gonna have to check in
with her to move from reality to reality
maybe it's just a matter of her astrally
projection projecting her consciousness
and whomever she's with to this next
reality and they're just kind of
visiting it or maybe she can kind of
like basically change the set of
everything around her so that everyone
is now waking up in the new reality and
they don't realize they're in the
reality but either way Wanda visions
gonna be the key to it and a character
Scarlet Witch is going to be kind of the
Shepherd to the new places in the
multiverse interesting and using a TV is
a is a good idea as well because those
other TV channels even though are tuned
into them are happening like right when
you switch over to a new show you're
jumping into it as it's in progress as
the episode is like halfway through as
opposed to like when you start a new
YouTube video or you start it from the
beginning or when you go to a new
website that website loads up for you so
the TV as kind of an analogue example of
this might help people understand this
idea of concurrent realities that are
already in progress right basically it's
saying anything is possible now
including new versions of things we've
already seen and basically our dream
scenario versus have already seen and
the fact that it's Disney behind this
Disney's it's just getting more and more
money and if it's just a matter of like
throwing money at Sony to buy all the
spider-man universes we could see a
story where it really is Andrew Garfield
Tobey Maguire Tom Holland and a new
actor playing Miles Morales maybe Donald
Glover all in a movie together get out
of my brain it's possible now I like the
idea that there's an alternate version
so all those alternate movies have
happened and there's an alternate new
rock stars are we swapped like is it
like until it just looks like this and
Eric looks like that no way do you feel
like you have a better understand civ
how the multiverse at least has been set
up so far yes yes would be interesting
to see is if in Marvel phase 4 the
characters who explain the rules of the
multiverse are Reed Richards like the
Fantastic Four they were smart you know
it's a smartest guy maybe he's from an
alternate reality and he's like okay
reality take me yeah he's so stretchy
he's so delicious okay well before we
continue with some bite-sized questions
we want to take a quick moment just to
talk about something that's important to
us folks
are you tired a big Wireless taken
advantage of you
you know those companies they can be
like Sith Lords just running Hydra from
inside Lex warp or something that's like
the most evil combination effort I hate
fees and bills that are high for no
reason like Indiana Jones with snakes
level hate so you hate them well mint
Mobile is a great solution and thanks to
MIT mobile for sponsoring this episode
MIT mobile can help you save more than a
thousand dollars a year on your wireless
bill there's a better way to get
Wireless and it's MIT mobile it's 10
times cheaper than your like normal big
Wireless yeah yeah but don't worry for
that cheaper price you don't have to
sacrifice performance whether you're
making calls or surfing the internet or
checking social media to see how many
likes your Aquaman fan or it is
happening how many is it I right now to
get your new wireless plan for just 15
bucks a month and get the plan shipped
to your door for free go to mint mobile
comm slash big Q again that's MIT mobile
comm slash big Q for a new wireless plan
for just 15 bucks $15 a month that's a
great deal okay on to some bite-sized
questions that Philip is gonna answer
for us we actually got some real mail
this time okay so our first one comes
from at solid bold who asks which metal
is stronger adamantium or vibranium and
why if they both exist in Marvel why
isn't Wolverine
why wasn't Wolverine may be using
vibranium and you have one minute and
then they're like we shouldn't matter
vibranium yeah no it's a it's an
interesting question so adamantium and
vibranium are both considered to be
crazy strong right eye but if I can
simplify it as much as I can
adamantium is a metal that it's special
property is that it is so incredibly
hard right it does not Bend and that's
the unique feature about this way
vibranium is actually shouldn't be
compared in terms of strength it does a
different thing entirely vibranium is
almost more similar to rubber
yeah it's super
can make weaves out of it in a minute
yeah so the fact that it vibrates what
it does is it's actually incredibly able
to bend and quickly retake its own form
so in the comics adamantium can actually
Pierce vibranium Wolverine has been able
to stabbed through Black Panthers
costume but vibranium is actually able
to take more of a hit and kind of keep
on ticking like the Energizer brother do
bunny right you have to beat him up and
he just to give me another moment killed
a lot of games he always gets back up
but the one thing that people might have
seen in the MCU is it's possible that
Thanos his sword maybe was made from
adamantium because it's able to destroy
caps shield its righteous made from
vibranium but it's hard to say I would
say technically if you mean which one's
harder its adamantium but which one is
like a better suit to make out of
adamantium suit kind of sucks actually
it's like a clunky yeah exactly
medieval so they're not the same kind of
thing but adamantium can pierce our
brain it's like your adamantium claws
Pierce this vibranium shirt that one
episode oh yeah over pencils but yeah
all right this one was mailed in to us
from Jaxon Stewart in it was awesome
he's a he's a Marine a Camp Pendleton
and he watches movies a one and a
half-year-old son Jackson and he sent us
this awesome Halloween the picture of
his son they watch their videos together
they're so nice to send us it's question
and help video watch that one episode or
a couple of these episodes recently one
half I don't know if he's learned
anything
everything about Palpatine sexual
history yes what do you guys think
became of caps broken shields which he
just brought up you think he kept it
maybe he gave it to Morgan after all so
that she could sled yeah so the actress
I think did use it for explain actually
uh if we have that but I so I went
painstakingly frame by frame and
rewatched endgame Oh know how sad my job
is it no it's fun I got to watch again
and I tracked it the whole way I really
tried to keep track of it the best I
could and it absolutely disappears at a
certain point there's a moment cap has
that shield all the way very close to
the near end of the movie but there
specifically a moment
we're thanos is trying to beat captain
marble to the quantum like device that's
in the back of Scott Lang's van and
Thanos throws his maybe adamantium sword
into the van and there's this huge shock
wave that goes off and we see a bunch of
characters just get blown away we don't
clearly see who gets blown away in that
moment but ever since that happened
after that we never see cap with the
shield again so likely that he just gets
separated from his shield at that moment
and then I feel like it might be
stretching a little bit but then you see
Captain Marvel and Thanos fight and
there's upload was highlighted in the
frame here I think it could be part of
the debris that you see back through you
kind of see a little bit of a star maybe
some circles around it so it's probably
in that debris field somewhere
but do I think somebody salvaged it and
sold it on Marvel eBay yes absolutely is
it possible that when that quantum
tunnel exploded the shield fragment got
sucked back in time yes that's what
happened and it immediately decapitated
Tony Stark's parents something it died a
whole different way yes all right and
thank you Jackson and Nathan Stewart for
watching our videos you guys are very
nice to me listen another piece of mail
we got was from the Brito family we have
a big question who lost their arm in
Star Wars the rise of Skywalker so this
question is about this theory of in
every movie somebody loses an arm no
matter what movie it is a bug's life
zimberg a god yeah it's gone I know in
Star Wars movies people are known for
losing limbs right I do have a list of
it's extremely common to lose more than
just an arm I hope you go to episode one
Darth Maul loses both legs episode two
Zam Wessel losers the yes her right arm
the a clay looses its legs and Anakin
actually not wanted to lose this that's
right yeah Count Dooku episode three
Count Dooku loses both hands General
Grievous loses two hands but he's still
finding mace windu loses his right hand
or Anakin loses his left arm and both
his legs and then a new hope that's a
famous one where pandabubba
loses his right eyes right Empire
Strikes Back a wampa loses its right arm
c-3po loses all of his limbs you just
can't find him and then that's one we're
famously Luke loses his right here and
then in Return of the Jedi
Vader loses his right hand but that's
actually like the only ones that are
established as definite arm losses if
you go to the new trilogy they actually
haven't shown limbs being cut ups they
show burns things like in deleted scenes
maybe someone bothering ya or something
we didn't see like c-3po again clearly
there's been an arm replacement because
yes right a right arm right so it wasn't
a requirement of the new trilogy that
they lose limbs but the one thing I'll
point out is my favorite thing to
acknowledge actually about some of the
cool stuff that happens in rise of
Skywalker if nobody lost their arm as
far as we can tell they are on Mustafar
which is where Anakin lost a lot of
limbs so there's limbs floating around
sure but while no one loses one it is
the only moment where someone gains one
because Palpatine when it finally is
taken from the Jedi gains an arm and
starts to regrow one he sucks energy out
of a dyad and the force exactly but it
does feel it does feel very purposeful
that they were trying to say like he's
doing a reverse pendulum right you know
closing that book again it's like poetry
so if they run okay well great answer
there thank you for all that research
and thank you for these questions we
have time for one more question of the
personal variety and this was sent in to
us any chance a person who it's wet and
sticky get this thing off me
this was sent to us by our buddy
undersea John discord and a reminder
that you can talk to it on discord
where we're getting our real hot takes
on these things and they come out by
becoming a patron in New York serves at
patreon.com slash new rock stars so one
of these guys is under siege and he
asked I wanna hear the story about the
lead up of Erik hitting Phillip in the
face punching me in the face he said
hitting and this is the mandel effect
thing that I was referencing because do
you seem to think that maybe this didn't
happen I remember a version of it but a
version so you though are known for your
steel trap and your memory what do you
think happened I remember we were in
college this is around and we were
driving it was in Gainesville Florida we
were driving on you
diversity Avenue Avenue yeah I remember
being Boulevard and Vendela it was you
and someone else's in the backseat and I
remember there was like some kind of
plushies ball like I was in the backseat
you were in the passenger seat and you
guys were throwing the ball back and
forth and I said I'm driving I'm driving
I can't be bothered right now and it
kept like clipping me and hitting me I'm
like guys I'm being distracted and I'm
really bad at multitasking I get really
really flustered like if I tried to like
talk on the phone and someone else is
talking I start screaming I just start
crying I wet myself and i black out for
four years and and then I get a college
degree and that's what you did yeah we
can have Bernie be through college the
but at some point you intentionally
grabbed it and he threw it at my face
and I said if you do that again I'm
gonna hit you and you threw it harder
and I don't remember punching you I kind
of blacked out
yeah you do just remember throwing my
hand no you can lift your you're
chanting you go ah you hit me I that is
that is sixty percent accurate okay
there so there's there was no balls
involved at all all right you just
completely added like you you're
thinking of like hacky sack in college
happen no balls
I thought it was an inflatable pretty
now it's much worse I think if I
remember correctly I super driving down
the road I was like trying to get you
pulled over or something it was like a
lot of saving our lives and you can't
well I like because I knew were so
flustered about driving in your car was
pretty new at the time same car same car
and I would yank the steering wheel but
not so bad that we died we didn't I and
then you another alternate reality yes
and then you did say if you do it again
I'm going to hit you and then I was like
this little [ __ ] especially that
version of you cut to picture Eric you
you weighed 68 pounds yeah now it's
buried under yeah no you were like so
you were this little like dough and then
and then I was like no he won't and so I
did it one more time and you did punch
me but you did it like this I didn't
have a fish I'm gonna no you did you did
okay well I'm gonna show you what you
did don't I'm gonna do
no because I'm also gonna do the same
hardness because this is payback after
all this time fair enough okay so you
look that way
yank my steering wheel and then I'm you
you you had to hype yourself up first
and I saw your eyes and then the
rearview mirror and you were like yeah
I'm gonna do it and then you did it and
knows about that heart there was a
deposit it was a knee jerk it was
instinctive appearances thirty Seconds
to work up the courage to do and I
thought I remember your reaction it was
more like you slid your knuckles top my
cheeks I do remember this that that
feeling I was like that might like my
head didn't move but everything it
wasn't a real punch so it wasn't a big
deal but I also I don't think it was
that hard I think it was a you did him
and it was more just like a stop but it
was like don't kill us you know what we
need we need to find the third person in
the car there was at least two other
people okay we need to find him who is
it we have a buddy named Spencer and has
a squeeky yeah purple stuff pj and
squeeze donkey dong Doug you want you
can have a free hood I don't know no I
already got my free hood man your mic is
like so no don't touch me
driving trying to land this bird in the
way in this bird
I don't like this I'm gonna throw I feel
so bad I'm so sorry the other one got
dryer that was yeah well guys this has
gotten wild oh gosh I'm like this will
call Phillipa nuber guys you can tweet
us at new rod stores with a hashtag
question and send mail at RPO box so we
can feature your letters and hopefully
though they'll get out of the splash
zone next time why is there a hair here
I'm sorry I'm just real quick
remembering that they there was a lot of
homoerotic energy to start this episode
and kind of a lot to end it to the real
book in a dick and uh yeah you know what
t-shirt I didn't intend to go that crazy
and subscribe to new rock stars here on
YouTube and subscribe if you're
listening to the podcast version
wherever you get your podcast and you
can follow us at Phillip Malina at ei
vas and we'll see you next week guys
[Music]